two Rangers from the monteverde
cloudforest reserve are out in search of
a kid style it's cool here in this part
of the forest and virtually the highest
point meaning they're almost guaranteed
to spot the fabled bird
and there he is revered by the Aztecs as
a deity today these birds are being hit
by climate change the winter was too
warm but there's no were here that's
higher where they can build their nests
and find food for their young we're here
at a thousand five hundred and fifty so
we're near the top of the mountain range
so that is why the concern if
temperatures continue to rise if that
affects the food sources for these birds
then they have nowhere to go and their
numbers would become ever more
restricted or more becoming smaller and
smaller
recardo winton grew up in this park he
knows all 400 species of bird that live
in the forest as well as those who pass
through at various times of the year one
feathered visitor that comes in the
spring towards the entire region
the three bottle bellbird also has an
altitude no migration they nest in this
mountain range but after nesting to go
to the Caribbean lowlands for North is
Nicaragua then we come around to the
Pacific lowlands around the Gulf of
nicoya and then come back up to nest
again in the motivate area that was a
symbol for the bell bird biological
corridor three waddled bell Birds cover
huge distances on their journey they
always need trees where they can rest up
here that's no problem but at lower
altitudes is not so easy the Costa Rican
government is working with local experts
like Shirley moody yo in an attempt to
draw as many species here as possible
she explains the idea of the biological
corridors is actually to connect that
from the cloud forest that we see over
there to the mangroves in the coast so
it's more than 16,000 Hector's that
we're trying to connect working with
private lands private landowners
actually and that's just one a 128
connecting corridors that are to be set
up across the country a quarter of Costa
Rica's land surface is under some form
of conservation protection but divided
into many small areas the idea now is to
connect them this involves holding talks
with the owners of large plantations for
example as they need to agree to give a
part of their land or plant a tree here
or there reforestation is also underway
at the other end of the biological
corridor on the Pacific coast and venado
island which has become a hot spot for
ecotourism
anat Reyes is very happy to show the
visitors around the beautiful island
where she lives the project that she
wants to show the group is called
paraiso escondido the hidden paradise
artificial flowers line the route
available everything what makes the
report station project so successful is
that the mangroves are natural to the
area and go practically by themselves
the eighth among living mackerel this is
the red mangrove tree that grows hang me
here and this is what we're using for
reforestation it grows really well it's
perfect the women are keen to protect
their home if the sea level continues to
rise the mangroves will help save the
coast from erosion and tidal waves the
trees can grow up to 20 meters tall in
just a few years buenas an grupo de
mujeres por mas por mujeres we're a
group of women and one man it's a family
project it's not easy work though we
have to carry heavy canisters of water
yes but it's a great project we all want
to do something to protect the
environment for a long time the
mangroves were cut down but they provide
a home to so many animals and so we want
to plant as many of them as possible
yeah looking at the same time which I
forgot there are numerous organizations
in Costa Rica that support reforestation
projects like this one in this case the
German Development Agency GI Z is also
involved along with a string of Costa
Rican organizations plus another German
company which is farming organic shrimps
here destined for the European market
not in the sea but in aqua cultures
subject to strict regulations from the
Costa Rican government
to get permission to farm the shrimp
here and then export them to Germany the
company had to commit in exchange to
help fund the reforestation with my bros
the three waddled bellbird also stops
here on the Pacific coast but only from
October onwards then the birds can be
found in the mangroves before they later
return to the cloud forests of
Monteverde linking the conservation
areas is a mammoth undertaking and a
worldwide first on this scale
you